so we made a few videos about relativity
and we've talked about how
distances change in relativity we talked
about how time changes in relativity
um so i thought i'd talk about something
which combines those two things together
which is how speed which is distance
divided by time changes in relativity
the previous videos we made we called a
gamma trilogy because they all had this
gamma factor in it actually one of the
interesting things about the way speed
transforms is that the gammas all
disappear they all cancel out so there
is no gamma in this game of video so we
need to think about uh how you measure
speed
let's say is this distance divided by
timer but particularly how it changes
depending on what reference frame you're
in so we need to think about how
different people measure speed in
different reference frames and so the
classic kind of thought experiment you
might do is you've got somebody on a
train
and we'll call what you call this
reference frame s prime and they're
going to roll a bowling ball along the
train
at some speed or other
and the train itself is moving so this
whole reference frame is moving if you
like in this direction at some other
speed v
and so the way on the train you'd
measure the speed is that you'd see how
far the ball in bowling ball had gone in
your reference frame
should we call this delta x how far it's
gone
prime because it's in your reference
frame
and at what time you know at some you
measure that at some time
delta t prime after you let go of the
ball
and then you could actually measure the
speed in your reference frame of that
bowling ball is just how far it's gone
divided by the time it took to get there
like that's the definition of speed is
how far something's gone divided by the
amount of time it took to get there is
the definition of speed
so that's in one reference frame so then
the question is what does the person in
this reference frame the other reference
frame see and let's deal with the
non-relativistic case first
okay so what what are they going to
measure the distance that they'll
measure that that ball has gone is going
to be how far the bowling balls rolled
away from you plus how far you've moved
down the line that extra distance how
far the train has moved depends on well
that's basically how fast the train was
going you're sort of adding it all on
top of each other exactly that's all
you're doing
so that that distance is v delta t the
train's going at some speed v and it's
traveled for some time delta t then the
distance it's covered is just the speed
times the time it's taken to do it so
now we can put all this stuff together
that says that delta x
is equal to so how far you see the ball
is having moved is how far the trains
moved plus how far the ball has moved
relative to the train just the sum of
the two and we can rearrange this in
non-relativistic case
to say that let's just divide through
delta x divided by delta t
is equal to v
plus delta x prime divided by delta t
and in this non-relativistic case we
don't have to worry about different
people seeing different times so it
doesn't matter whether that's delta t or
delta t prime we can call it the same
thing it's all the same thing or we can
rewrite this again that just says that
the speed that you see the balls moving
is equal to v so that's delta x by delta
t
plus the speed that the person on the
train sees the ball moving and that as
you said is just basically you just add
the speeds right the speed at which the
bowling ball is moving is the speed that
the ball is moving relative to the train
plus the speed that the train is moving
relative to you right that's the simple
galilean transformation no relativity
everything works sensibly in the way
we're used to it working the reason why
people get interested in this is that
one of the things that everyone says in
relativity is you can't ever travel
faster than light
and so one obvious question you could
ask is well why can't i just get to
travel faster than light by doing these
kind of additions in that is supposing
instead of rolling a bowling ball the
person on the train was actually shining
a torch along the train then the torch
beam would be indeed be traveling at the
speed of light relative to them and then
if you ask well how fast would the torch
be then be traveling relative to you
well it would be the speed of light plus
the speed that the train's moving away
from you and that's faster than the
speed of light
exactly
it's sorted unfortunately relativity
takes care of that and it's not really
the way that things work
so we need to start again but we need to
now do the problem properly with
relativity this is your minute physics
audition professor
unfortunately my drawing is not quite up
to the job i suspect
and then we got the other
chaps in here
moving along at some speed v
okay now previously the formula we had
said that
the distance the
bowling ball is
down the line is equal to the distance
on relative to the train plus how far
the trains moved now what the extra
factor that we haven't put in yet is
special relativity and as we saw before
what special relativity does is
introduces these factors of gamma and so
the this galilean transformation that we
had before is a little bit modified by
an extra factor of gamma in front of it
gamma is one over the square root of one
minus v squared over c squared and we
have a whole series of videos you can go
and watch about gamma should you wish to
do so but then the other thing we know
about relativity is that not only does
the distance depend on what reference
frame you're in but actually the time
depends on which what reference frame
you're in
and so the we need the equivalent
transformation for that so there are
these things called lorentz
transformations that's the first of them
and then this is the other larynx
transformation we need turns out these
are the two lorenz transformations you
need okay so now we can say okay so
what's the speed
as measured from the person who's
standing beside the track watching the
train go by and we just do the same
thing that we did before we just the
speed is just the distance divided by
the time so we can just divide them
you know with delta x
divided by delta t is equal to now the
gammas are going to cancel because if we
divide that by the other we end up with
the gamma on the top and going around
the bottom so we can just cancel them
out and i'll do a little bit of tidying
up i'll divide top and bottom through by
delta t prime so i can just write this
as delta x prime over delta t prime this
is kind of the answer that we wanted
because delta x over delta t is the
speed of the bowling ball or whatever it
is that's being thrown along the train
as seen from the person by signing
standing beside the track
and delta x prime over delta t prime is
the speed as seen by the person on the
train so i can write that in terms of
the u's and u primes that we had before
this just says that u is equal to u
prime plus v divided by one plus that's
a u prime again
v
over c squared
which is the final answer
in the non-relativistic limit so that
what we were looking at before the
galilean transformation so both u prime
and v are small compared to the speed of
light that means this term is small so
this thing's just one basically and that
just says that the speed you see is just
the sum of the speed of the ball
relative to the train and the train
relative to you which is the answer we
have before so that's right it kind of
comes out right if things aren't close
to speed of light but okay but now let's
do the
the more interesting case of actually
where the relativity really matters and
in particular let's go to the really
extreme case of actually instead of
rolling a bowling ball along the train
let's shine a light beam along the train
so in that case u-prime the speeder that
whatever it is relative to the train is
equal to the speed of light and let's
see what happens when we put that in
there so in that case we end up with if
u prime
is equal to the speed of light then u
is equal to u prime is just the speed of
light
plus v
divided
by 1
plus u prime is the speed of light cv
over z squared
now let me just do a little bit of
playing around with this so i'll rewrite
the top here
as c
into one so pull that factor out plus v
over c
because if i multiply this out i just
end up with c plus
c v over c which is just v so c plus v
divided by
and then all i'm going to do here is
cancel the c over c squared so i end up
with 1
plus
v over c
which you'll notice is just the same as
the term there so this is the same as
that which just basically means that
this whole thing is just equal to the
speed of light still
so there's the bizarre thing that we've
taken we've remember what we've done
here is said okay so there's a light
beam that's moving relative to the train
at the speed of light now if you're
watching from beside the train what
speed you see that light beam going at
the answer is still the speed of light
you haven't actually added to its speed
at all and i guess the physics behind it
is that actually you really have to
worry about both space and time
being changed by what reference frame
you're in which means that not
surprisingly the speed that comes out at
the end
is going to be changed in a slightly
strange way as well and it turns out
that relativity takes care of this
invariance of the speed of light that no
matter what reference frame you're
watching of light beam travel from
you'll always see it traveling at the
speed of light is the universe
wanting to keep things at the speed of
light and everything changes to cater
for that or does everything change all
the time and the speed of light just
falls out of that
is it chicken or egg
it's a very good question and i actually
really like your first explanation that
actually the universe arranges things in
such a way
that the speed of light always comes out
as the speed of light and no matter how
much you mess around with things by
trying to run away from a light beam or
run towards it when you come to measure
its speed you'll always find that its
speed comes out as the speed of light
and everything else kind of adjusts the
distances and the times adjust in just
such a way so that when you come to
combine those distances in times to
measure a speed for a light beam it will
always come out as a speed of light is
there something that
is important about the speed of light
being constant and unchanging
so what motivated einstein to come up
with all this in the first place is he
had this idea that the laws of physics
should be the same whatever reference
frame you're in so if you're in a sealed
box there should be no experiment you
can do that will tell you whether that
seal box is moving at a constant speed
or is stationary and in fact it's even
in his view of things a kind of a
meaningless question
and what he also knew is that the speed
of light comes out from the laws of
electromagnetism
and so
then the question is okay so but in what
in what reference frame do those laws of
physics work and his argument is that
those laws of physics should work in
whatever reference frame you're in
which means that actually the speed of
light has to be invariant if you believe
that the laws of physics are the same in
all the different reference frames
what if it hadn't been that way what if
the universe has said nah that can be
different for different reference frames
like would like would you and i be
ripped to pieces in some cosmic rip or
would the universe just be a bit
different and quirky like does the
universe benefit from the fact this is
what happens
i get i mean it's very hard to construct
a universe in which this wasn't true in
retrospect it's hard to construct a
universe in which this isn't true bear
in mind that for example you know all
the other things that come from
relativity kind of flow from that so i
think famous things like e equals m c
squared all flow from this invariant to
the speed of light
and that means that
the equivalence of mass to energy is
actually a natural consequence of
relativity and so for example what
powers the sun fusion converting mass
into energy
wouldn't work
and if we weren't living in a
relativistic universe now you could
imagine that the universe the laws of
physics in such a universe will come up
with some other way of generating you
know energy from fusion but the picture
we currently have of it really would be
completely different
and the quantity of the speed of light
the the the speed that it actually is
does that matter like would the universe
be the same if the speed of light had
been halved or it was quite you know if
it was something close to the speed we
walk at like does it need to be as
fast as it is to our human brains so it
comes out the laws of electromagnetism
so it's to do with how strong
electric fields are how strong magnetic
fields are
which are really just arbitrary
constants of nature as far as we know
which
which i guess means that actually the
speed of light which is some combination
of these things is also an arbitrary law
of nature
the universe would be a very strange
place if the speed of light were very
much slower because of course all these
relativistic effects that lead to all
the weird things that come out of
relativity we don't usually have to
worry about them in everyday life but if
it actually turned out that the speed of
light you know was walking pace then all
sorts of strange relativistic effects
would happen every time you walk to the
post box you know it would be you would
have to worry about all the relativistic
time dilation and length contraction
effects so to be like if i go and post
this letter is it going to am i going to
die before i get there or yeah or will
have all your relatives have died of old
age before you get home again so yes
indeed it would be a very very strange
universe so the light instead of going
straight up and down follows a path like
that
so it has further to go
from our perspective that light's gone
further
but also the speed of light is the same
in every reference frame